le le questionnaire 1 le questionnaire
alors robert badinter votre mot préféré
justice le mot vous détestez racisme le
vote drogue favorite le travail
le son le bruit que vous aimez la vague
bruit de la mer et le son le bruit que
vous détestez allik l'accent et le votre
juron gros mot blasphème favori merde
c'est pas mieux c'est pas non plus n'a
fait sic et vous n'avez jamais changé je
crois pas non non non classique guidel
vous êtes finalement très classe et même
homme ou femme pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque
j'étais sérieusement condorcet pour me
faire plaisir elisabeth badinter et puis
c'est un mur est offert pas du tout non
mais je n'ai jamais voulu
oui au contraire d'abord il a fait une
publicité fun assad s'était pas loin de
ses bienfaits bon le métier vous
n'auriez pas aimé faire bourreau en 80
et aujourd'hui génie civil à la retraite
d'ailleurs je veillais ce qui est d'une
pension la plante l'arbre l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné le
renard le renard parce qu'il veut
toujours être libres rappelé plus tôt
car dans l'est que je la coupe et que
d'être retenu dans le piège
le renard le renard dans une émission et
rod et je n'en ai pas dit
khadija temps et mutilé l'animal della
libertà apaloo c'est oui voilà et enfin
si dieu existe qu aimeriez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire avoue
robert badinter
tu as fais ce que tu as pu rentrer
[Musique]